Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to take a look at Niagara Optimization.
We're going to first look at our performance checklist that we can hit when it comes to
developing and creating our effects for our scene.
So let's get started.
One of the things you can use and create when it comes to Niagara is create a Niagara effect
type.
Now that Niagara effect type can be found under effects and then you'll find Niagara
effect type.
This Niagara effect type will then be loaded into our scene in Niagara underneath our system
effect type in our overview node.
So this overview node is the blue node here that has a lot of our heavy lifting settings
in here that we can control and we're going to go to system and then we're going to load
our Niagara effect type here.
Let's go and take a look at this in Unreal and I'll show you how to set this up.
So to create a Niagara effect type we're going to right click here and we're going
to go to our effects and we're going to go to advanced and you'll see a Niagara effect
type.
I'm going to click on this and we'll just call this demo so Niagara effect type and
then we'll do demo and I'm just going to enter double click on it and you can see that we
have several properties to choose from.
Some of the key properties and workflows which we'll also point out in the slides is
being able to control our system scalability in which we can hit plus here, open this up
and we can choose how we want to degrade or I should say dumb down the effect in our scene.
There's also visibility calling that we can control and there's also budget scaling that
we can also edit.
You'll see there's a emitter scalability settings also.
We can hit a plus here, open this up and also choose low, medium, high for our needs.
We're going to take a look at one that I've already built and exactly where to put things.
You'll notice there's also validation as well as performance.
This performance allows us to be able to control a thing called Niagara baseline control basic
which we can load in performance and if we load this in here we can now open this up
and we'll be able to look at a baseline control that is in here to be able to control number
of instances, test duration as well as the overall system.
If you were to load a system in here that we need to be able to reference.
Let's go ahead and take a look at this at our effect in general in our scene.
In my scene here I have an effect placed in here.
I'm going to double click on this effect and we're going to go to our overall overview
here of our effect here.
You'll notice things slowed down just a little bit there.
What do you can actually help in and I do recommend this when you are working with your
effect is to just pause or even stop that playback.
That's going to make things run a bit easier.
This is our Niagara overview node and in here we're going to load it underneath our effect
type and you also want to make sure you turn on your fixed bounds when you're assembling
everything.
This is where you're going to load it and that reference that effect type that we had
created and the settings we put in there.
Now our effect is going to reference that in outputting what we need.
So again this allows us to control when it spawns, its scalability and its overall performance.
Again, like I said, you want to make sure you turn on fixed bounds.
Most systems should use it.
It's cheaper and required for GPU emitters and make sure the bounds are not bigger than
they need to be.
Let me tell you what I'm talking about here because when you mess with your bounds you
can mess with your overall look and feel and performance of your object.
We're also going to talk a little bit about resolution too.
So again fixed bounds can be found right here underneath our effect type and then you can
control how that fixed bounds is played out.
What I do want to mention, what you heard me just say about resolution and you'll hear
me mention this several times because it's very important to consider, you need to consider
the size of your overall effect versus, and we can pick on this particular one here, your
overall effect versus your resolution.
Now you can control the overall size of your object and how it actually relates to your
scene.
Now that size directly correlates with your resolution max axes.
So notice mine is at 192.
So if I increase the size of my world space size and I don't necessarily increase my resolution,
I'm going to get hit with some pixels and you'll see the kind of the voxel or pixelation
happening with our effect and you want to be careful with that.
So you need to fine tune and balance between the size of your object and world space versus
your resolution max axis.
So it's really important to not forget that.
Now because my computer is pretty strong graphically, I could probably bump this up to 200, maybe
get close to 300 and be okay, but this is where we want to control it.
Now you can control that resolution inside of the effect itself, but I don't recommend
it.
This is kind of where you want to be able to dial things down.
And again, your world space, if you make it too big, you're spreading that effect a little
bit too thin and you could get major pixelation if you're not careful, but it also depends
on the effect itself.
Also make sure the warmup in the system properties, warmup time, warmup tick count is set to zero.
Warmup is extremely expensive and it causes hitches and only works on CPU emitters.
So keep that in mind.
Check each emitter scalability setting and make sure that they are on the right platform,
turn off what is not needed.
So if you don't need it, turn that off for sure.
Again, if you're using the component renderer experimental in scalability, leave cinematic
and epic on.
Check system scalability overrides and edit them as needed, not needed in all effects,
overrides used to, they are used to adjust plane and effect timing.
Note more for interactive and final pixel.
So in a case of ICV effects, you may not necessarily have to touch these.
That's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to take a look at debugging your Niagara effect.
Thanks again.